[Musique]
première prise en main pour dimitri con
toda la station d'épuration du grand
prado à sainte-marie péter chef
d'entreprise suite à l'accident
j'ai tout laissé de côté j'étais obligée
par rapport aux activités que je faisais
avant l'âge élagage travaux de cordis et
donc tout ça c'est plus adapté
après un accident de moto porteurs d'un
handicap aux membres inférieurs
à 39 ans il cherche du travail depuis
plus d'un an ou tous ce matin j'ai fait
son arcueil où on a pris un petit moment
pour voir la maquette de lusine dimitri
il m'a dit clairement il faut faire
abstraction son handicap donc considéré
comme quelqu'un de normal donc en ce
sens
j'ai quand même
mis en avant avec lui qui avait la
possibilité dû prendre l'ascenseur au
lieu de faire des escaliers gps étapes
de traitement le prétraitement équipés
et bien accompagné dimitri suit
attentivement son tuteur pour cette
journée intitulée les duos des années de
mesurer le voile debout et rapidement
les prises d'initiatives montre bien la
motivation au travail
les patrons ne savent pas ce qu'ils vont
les futurs sarrail et c'est à nous de
faire nos preuves d'une part et de
montrer nos qualités qu'on peut avoir
c'est quoi comme formation toi on n'est
pas pour nous c'est clair que dimitri a
vraiment quelque chose à apporter de
très fort c'est un message pour dire que
malgré son handicap il est capable de
faire le travail au quotidien et même
beaucoup plus et en termes d'exemplarité
en termes de responsabilité c'est super
importante parce que justement nous nous
sommes en pleine phase de projet
d'entreprise et toutes ces valeurs pour
nous ce sont vraiment les fondamentale
impulsée par le département
cette initiative donne un nouveau
souffle et créent du lien pour les
personnes éloignées de l'activité mais
ce jour là il n'y avait que des
personnes motivées
[Musique]